chris flexon first year mariner who's
been as reliable as they come in the
american league flexing getting set to
face an a's lineup that is credibly
short-handed with injury
checked foul back 95 mile an hour
elevated fastball from flexon for round
number one
chapman finds himself batting second now
one of the highest strikeout rates of
any hitter in the american league the
2-2
another strikeout he paints 95 once
again consecutive two-out singles
here's seth brown
and that one has hit high and deep to
right field haniger back hannigan near
the wall hanagar leaps and
that baby is gone just out of the reach
of a leaping hanger and the a's lead
three to nothing just out of the reach
of mitch haniger
pack your bags brownie all aboard next
stop
pound town
cole irvin
needs to figure out a way to beat the
seattle mariners this is the fifth time
that he has faced
them this year and he's owen four
let's hit hard on what happened right to
kemp
that's out number one
france works a walk and mitch hadiger
coming up to pitch to hannigan swinging
a miss struck him out 93 miles an
hour the o2 is swung on a miss and cole
irvin strikes out hanniger in seeger
after he walked france with one away
here's abraham toro
and he got him swinging
foul tip that's the third strikeout for
cole irvine and the mariners have two on
with one away
so here's tom murphy
murphy bounces one to chapman chapman
fires to second for one on to first and
olson stays with it and that's a five
four three double play here's matt
chapman for the second time
this is helpful he swings away the first
pitch pops it up on the infield
seeger camps out underneath one pitch
one out olson with a base hit to left
field his first time up
to the point of the shift over there
towards toro and what there's three
pitches and two outs
on the heels of a quick and tidy second
flexon gets the first two easily here in
the third two two pits swaying and a
misses sliding at him good ending for
chris fletcher he's retired the last
three six seven batters good situation
for the mariners first two runners on
now you get to ty france
france
lifts this out towards the alleyway and
right center field pender can't get to
it here comes dylan moore jp crawford is
on his heels he holds at third dylan
scores standing and ty france puts the
mariners on the board it's an rbi double
now the mariners cooking here in the
third inning one out two on
got him swinging big strikeout for cole
irvin so two away two ounce two on so
hopefully luis who had a base hit his
first time uh and drive these two runs
in
hard head and past the dive of the
shortstop machine
crawford and right behind him ty france
and with this luis terrence has tied it
up in the bottom of the third
rbi opportunity for chris davis
here's a 2-1 a swing and a soft liner
left center field that's going to get
down pinder's coming around third and he
will score the ahead run an rbi single
for chris davis and the a's are back
ahead four to three
as kd delivers his ninth rbi of the year
county second murphy at first mariners
down a run
up the middle and into center field for
a base hit koenig is coming home and jp
crawford has tied this game in the
fourth murphy who is now at second base
representing the go ahead run here is ty
france
up the middle and into center field
ty france has put the mariners in front
an rvi single and it's five four
mariners in the bottom of the fourth
inning here is mitch are looking for
more three one to hannigar
barrel crush this is on its way
three run home run
mitch haniger
blowing the doors off the ace in the
fourth inning
peter middle away at 90.
that is crushed exit below 105 410 feet
36 home run of the year for henniger two
ounces two on flexson has
reset now and the pitch one on fly ball
shallow right center field on the run
celtic jarrod is there and he makes the
catch and in one pitch he gets brown
after throwing 12 to mark cannon
you got to love this game the baseball
we go to the top of the sixth inning
what a ball game mariners eight and the
athletic sport first guy out is casey
sadler
jp charges plenty of time for round
number one
[Applause]
get on the ground here's chris davis
swung on backhanded by secret third one
hop throw over the first tie france digs
it out two down one ball and one strike
on the ground toro swung over the shift
well that had the makings of a quick
inning for casey sadler
well well well mitch haniger batting
with two men aboard once again one out
two on
bottom six
he's got another it's his second
three-run home
he has just kicked the teeth in on the
a's
have a night his first time up he had a
fastball out of the ballpark
this time as a breaking ball exit v low
again at 105. 421 feet 54 appearances
for sean doolittle facing his former
team and facing batters nine one and two
here in the top of the seventh
machine breaks his back but it's got
enough carry to make a routine catch for
hannigan two pitches one out
the 2-2 pitch swung on popped up seeger
taking a look coming in he's got room
third base side plenty of room right at
the t-mobile sign right below the third
base coaches box and that's out number
two
swinging and a miss doolittle retires
his side in order bases loaded two outs
for ty france
back kicks off the picture and it rolls
into left field count again murphy is
high step at home now the meritors get
two more runs
it's a forehead night for ty france and
andres is on to close it down in the
ninth inning fastball 91 miles an hour
has a curveball and a changeup that he
will use his speed 34th appearance on
the year 47 in the third 47 strikeouts
for matt
now number one
whether it be a single game or a week's
worth
murphy holds on to it for round number
two
and that's it that's the ball game the
mariners win it they man handle the a's
tonight
a season best 13 runs
the mariners a game and a half outside
of the second wild card they've won nine
of their last 11 and they kick off this
home stand in fine fashion